foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving in storage Studio
what's up America it's the Ramsay show
and we are hanging out to have a
conversation about your life your
relationships your mental health your
money oh I'm John deloney joined here by
best-selling author and all around
pretty good human being Rachel Cruz and
we're taking your calls on whatever's
going on in your life triple eight eight
two five five two two five calls
toll-free triple eight eight two five
five intro
George and Ken like overall good human
being or is that like my intro because
they're not you say it every time we're
on the show together so I'm like is that
everybody or is that like no you say
that about everyone
overall good human being as though we're
on a date and hey it's like and you're
like oh do you tell everybody that
they're pretty is that what you're
asking overall good human being I'm
gonna take as my own I'm claiming it
that is my title I've I've never said
George Campbell's no for all good human
being okay okay just because I'm
committed to telling the truth on this
show that's just like one of the things
it's one of the things let's go to uh
Jenny in Charlotte what's up Jenny
hey Dr John hey Rachel thanks for taking
my call absolutely how can we help
you're more than a pretty good human
being there Rachel come on come on I
appreciate you I appreciate you Jenny
I'm so glad you're the first time
pandering myself
so quickly every Christmas at least one
person I know gets smart money smart
kids as a book oh yeah you're pretty
great I'm so glad change in the Next
Generation I love it that's right that's
right a quick question for you guys I'm
gonna try to make a long story short
Austin was so great talking to him
um we live in a pretty wealthy area of
Charlotte where you hardly ever see a
homeless person last week I saw a gal
tucked way behind not holding a sign not
asking for anything so my ultimate
question is regarding boundaries with a
non-family member but a homeless person
that I've gotten to know pretty well
over the last week or so because I've
been doing you know a Dave routine of
like let's write down your goals where
do you want to go next she's obviously
kind of a user not kind of a user she is
a user and so so when I met her that day
we chatted for a little bit said what
would you like she said can you get me a
sandwich sure came back talked to her
more and I told her that I called all
the local shelters in the area and all
five of them had a wait list and three
of them required a substance abuse
program first and she said well thanks
for looking into that you know I left
later that night when my husband got
home it was raining and he said let's
just go check on her I know you probably
can't stop thinking about her went back
to check on her she just really wanted
to go back home she was 35 miles away
that someone just gave her a ride
hopefully to you know get to a nicer
area like ours so we paid for an Uber
for her to go back home
um with you know her two shopping carts
worth of things and unfortunately I did
give her my phone number because I just
wanted to make sure she was safe she got
back that 35 miles and now she's calling
me constantly like a few times a day and
now we've kind of whittled down the
conversations from an hour and a half to
now five minutes and I'm just trying to
encourage her Lisa did you go take your
bike up to Bojangles did you are you
looking at your kids names every day
what's your three week goal what's your
three-month goal and how do you be a
giving believer but not an able and like
what and how do I get rid of my guilt of
like oh man I just wanted to move in
with me which won't happen but um but
how how do you guys handle someone that
you know needs a lot but you like I said
don't want to enable and I'm a huge fan
of Dr Henry Cloud's book but he talks
more about relatives and not new really
in need friends
um so here's here's how me and my family
have have navigated this one
um I this just this is this the way the
deloney's do it okay so this isn't a
prescription
um I err on the side of
um
over loving than I do under loving and
it was a conversation I had with a psych
Professor one of my close mentors
several years ago when he said I stopped
asking
why won't that person quit drinking and
I started asking what is gone so
sideways in this person's life who hurt
this person to the degree that what
choices were made Downstream that this
is the only way they can get through a
day
and that was a transformative moment for
me because it allowed me to walk and be
in relationship with somebody instead of
walking towards somebody with my
judgment in hand right so in our house
we do err on the side of I'm going to be
over giving
um and I also have had to come to terms
with this and this is hard two important
facts one
um often the downstream things are three
things the downstream things like Global
boards and are you doing these
activities those all come behind I need
a place to to sleep and I need food and
I need water right
um we often want to solve these big
existential issues with folks and
they're just hungry right or um they're
drinking because of what they had to do
this morning to get food right and so
it's that's that's number one number two
you've you've seen it presence is often
once the basic needs are met human
connection and presence is intoxicating
it's such a powerful thing right and
that's it doesn't surprise me that
you're getting calls all the time here's
where I struggle most is I have to
recognize my limitations and I've got to
let Professionals in my local area who
are tied into resources who are
connected to addiction therapists I've
got a lot of grad school I'm not I'm not
a trauma I'm I can respond to trauma I'm
not a long-term I got to know my
limitations is what I'm saying and
here's the final thing and this one's
the hardest
eventually somebody has to decide that
they want to make their life different
and you can put food in front of folks
you can you can provide resources and
you can provide care
um
but somebody at some point has to make
the decision that they are going to
accept resources they're going to get on
the wait list they're going to start
taking their meds they're going to go
sit with a local Pastor a local church
who's got resources to help in the gap
between the the shelters right someone's
going to have to decide I'm going to be
willing to be a part of that you can't
make somebody be well I guess is what
I'm what I'm trying to say
um and ultimately people I think have to
come to like how can I sleep tonight and
I've got friends who let people just
come stay at their house and I've got
friends who write enormous checks and
I've got friends who work at the rescue
mission here in Nashville I got friends
who are all in all different spectrums
and ultimately I'm not going to get in
the business of judging somebody I am in
the business of what if as for me in my
house right and I think that's where
ultimately where you have yeah
just here's what that looks like you're
a pretty remarkable woman yeah
incredible not many people would stop
let alone have the steps that you that
you took and even and even feeling like
as I'm thinking about her on a rainy
night and then actually going to do
something to go do something yeah so
Jenny your heart your heart's just
amazing I just want to encourage you in
that but I think at the end of the at
the end of the day what John said my
like always basic lies like you can't be
the hero in everyone's story like
there's a factor that they have to play
as well
um where that encouragement comes in
from you possibly from time to time
right and what what you what your
bandwidth is but being able to hand her
the resources that she needs from the
basics to even the mental health like
John was saying I think is really wise
so I would reach out to folks in your
area they've got wait list great I would
reach out to local pastors social local
social workers and see if you can get
her connected with some resources that
would be Bridge resources until she can
get a place to stay thank you so so much
for having a great heart we'll be right
back
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
joined by a great great person Rachel
Cruz and we're taking your calls on
money life mental health relationships
whatever's going on Triple eight eight
two five five two two five so one of I
feel like it's now become a pastime on
the show where we'll take Financial
advice we've seen outs as you would say
the internets and say oh is that good
advice is that bad advice so Credit
Karma their Tick Tock accounts is just
full of
[Music]
wonderful things so this one came up uh
and I was like oh that's that's a
fascinating take so John you're gonna
you're gonna just get right now on
that's that's next oh okay okay here's
the video first yeah okay let's do this
one thing that's cool about becoming an
adult is that it's very embarrassing to
not have a credit card do you have a
credit card Shannon
[Music]
first of all you have to understand what
a credit card is Alexa can you explain
to me what a credit card is all I know
is that you swipe and get free money
then you need to know how to use it to
your benefit and again what perks do you
get from your credit card I think I get
like airline miles or something maybe
like a trip to Mexico and then you need
to figure out which one to apply for
credit karma is the secret life hack
everyone needs in their life to make
things a little easier than searching
for a new credit card you can explore
different kinds of cards and the best
part is that you can see your chances of
approval before even applying
earn your credit to look on Credit Karma
nope and it's free so if you want to
make the most informed decision before
applying for a credit card go check out
Credit Karma you won't be disappointed
hey can I just ask you something when
you're hanging out because like I've
just been with a lot of like a lot of
rooms with guys just hanging out doing
stuff oh yeah have you ever
back do you and your friends get
together do you all like say the same
thing together
if your friends is knitting do you all
go hey you want to stay at the same time
the only time I say the same phrase with
someone as George Campbell these days
and this is smart money happy yeah or we
say that at the same time that's about
that's the closest in unison I get uh so
so let's we'll we'll talk about it in a
second that's gross but what's fun that
was just gives me the Ooze oh okay she's
just like
uh we're never just shaming it's like I
know if you don't want to be the loser
you don't want to yeah if you don't have
a credit card because there's a level of
like that of that social
tribal right idea that's like I want to
plug in and when you're on the outs
we're gonna just smug and but you're it
literally kicks brain chemistry in
action to get you back into your tribe
right and so videos like that are are
not not only are they deceptive and
they're like not cool but they have
actual physiological chemical like
responses in people's bodies they're
like oh I don't know I don't want my
friends what am I missing you want to be
the weirdo what am I doing what am I
doing wrong yeah so one of their big
selling points though in that Tick Tock
video specifically was that you can get
pre-approved like you can know if you're
pre-approved before you ask actually
apply for a credit card so now they're
actually being sued Credit Karma by the
FTC FTC uh because they are falsely
pre-approving people for credit cards so
the same thing that they're like
encouraging being like Oh yeah we can do
this
they're being sued for so man
God bless God bless credit card
companies just trying to get you people
in the afternoon those complaint
allegeset from these dates to these
dates Credit Karma falsely told many
consumers they had been pre-approved for
credit offers
leading consumers to apply incur a hard
inquiry in the credit reports and if
they're denied potentially damage their
credit scores unnecessarily that part I
don't even care about like I mean I I
don't like it they're lying to their
potential customers
um and they're hurting their credit
reports I just I that's more Insidious
because kids live on Tick Tock and it's
propaganda it's gross yeah well and it's
like the sarcasm a little bit behind it
of like so do you know what it is I
don't know I think it's just like free
money and it's like showing this like
uneducate what feels uneducated I know
they're just trying to be snarky about
it but that snarky is it's just free
money or you just get free airline miles
yes oh that's what a credit card keeps
into like the idea and it's like oh I'm
learning something yeah through this
Tick Tock and gross gross on a stick in
a box
all right let's go to Jared in Detroit
I just let's Jared bring us some good
stuff man because that gives me the the
hi there thanks a million for having me
on the show thank you two million what's
up man
so I'm a current college student I'll be
finished at the end of 2023. what are
you studying um I'm 20 years old I'm
studying engineering mechanical
engineering nice excellent and then I've
and then I just got married this past
August as well ah congratulations
thank you
um so my wife and I both we've
Consolidated our finances and we have
about thirty thousand dollars to invest
um beyond all of our expenses
and our emergency fund and we're
debating what we should do with that
money
so I'll be finished with school in 2023
we're debating if we want to continue to
live in an apartment until
um my wife finishes school
or if we want to invest that money
somewhere else and so I'd like your
advice on what we should do with that
what do you want to do after 2023 like
2024 what does life look like for you
guys if you're just a dream
um so
my my wife will finish college at the in
the spring of 2024
and from there we have no idea where
we'd like to live
um precisely but I do have a really good
position right now and I see the
strongest option for us to to stay in
the current area that we're in
especially because family is close
um
yeah okay well Jared if I were you guys
you're just in a lot of transitions
still from being in school you guys just
got married there's a lot of moving
pieces and because of that what life
could look like yeah you know in in the
fall of 2024 uh two years from now you
know you you it's almost like you can't
predict it because you guys have so many
moving pieces and yes I know you kind of
have like a hunch that we may be staying
close by
um so if I were you because how old are
you guys
um so I'm 20 years old and my wife is
19. okay they are very sharp very mature
very uh great at savings I didn't know
what day it was when I was 19 Jared way
to go man to be that agent have this
money saved good grief uh so Jared if I
were you guys I would hang on to it okay
I'd hang on to that money make sure you
guys get through school debt free
um make sure that you guys are
continuing to live within your means
like all of this stuff that you guys are
doing there's no rush right so I if I
were you I would save that because
probably what's going to happen you're
going to probably end up saving more
into that account I would just put it in
a money market account and then I would
probably think by in two years you guys
are gonna have an idea of where you're
gonna land and you're gonna have a
really nice down payment for a house I
would probably look at it as a future
down payment but I would not okay I
would not pull the trigger on that as of
today because of this transition of just
getting married and still in school all
the moving pieces renting right now I
know it feels like you're throwing money
away
but it's a low risk it's a low risk move
and I and I would just do that I think
you guys are okay for two years and you
guys are gonna be fine so don't feel the
urgency like I have to invest this 30
000 into the market because we're gonna
lose Building Wealth all that you will
get to that and you will be just fine I
promise Jared I'm not the picture of
stability nobody's ever accused me of
that
um
right before my senior year in college I
had a plan on who I was going to marry I
had a plan on where I was going to be
um
professionally
and I was in one city
and right when I graduated
um right before I graduated
I broke we broke up I ended up in
another state and then a few months
after that I ended up going back to
visit my parents and ran into my old
high school track coach who then
um we sat down and talked and I ended up
a high school teacher and yet another
city in another state and then I got
back together with that person and we've
been married for 20 years why'd I tell
you that you have no idea what the next
three to four to five to six to seven to
ten months looks like okay and so
Rachel's wisdom is again you probably
aren't going to get whiplashed around
like I am because I'm pretty unstable
pretty unstable he's an engineer sounds
like you now yeah probably
um but
sit tight maybe the thing you need to
practice over the next six months is
breathing laughing go to a concert go
have fun live outside the spreadsheet a
little bit and enjoy your life okay
you're doing a great great job we'll be
right back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
thank you
foreign
eight two five five two two five this is
the Ramsey Show let's go out to Jenny in
Toronto Canada hey Jenny what's up
hi there John and Rachel thank you for
taking my call today you got it what's
up
um a couple days ago I found a deposit
slip in my car my husband had left there
that showed uh our small business
account had uh over six thousand dollars
in debt on it and uh I was on the
understanding that we were on baby steps
four five and six uh I confronted him
about it and he said oh that's all
overheads but have uh you know come up
in the last couple weeks
and uh I went and I looked at his last
um business bank statement as well and I
saw that it was actually uh over ten
thousand dollars in small business debt
since before August
and this is a pretty big issue for us
because uh when we finished baby steps
three at the end of August I left my
corporate job to stay home with our two
kids so uh he is very sensitive about
this issue got very defensive when I
tried to talk to him so it's just uh
lying under the surface right now
um so how do I talk to him and do we use
our emergency fund to pay off this debt
uh two things here
um one this this has very little to do
with debt
this has to do with you finding out that
your husband stared you squaring the
eyes and lied to you
yeah and it's about something that you
two had both put your hands in and said
go team we're all in this together and
then he went and did this and so there's
it's not like y'all had never talked
about debt and you found a credit card
this is y'all are consciously working
towards building a different kind of
life and then this happened on the side
and then he lied to you about it
um anytime something like this pops up
like all of a sudden out of nowhere
somebody goes in and runs up 10 grand
and is trying to move this shell over
here and this shell over there
um
my my inclination right or wrong is he
seeing somebody or he's an addiction has
gotten out of control is there any
possibility of those two things
I would have said no but this is really
uh really shocked me really really
shocked me
um it's uh he's always been sensitive
about finances because he took over a
family business this was family business
um and there was debt associated with
that and he had to have some tough
conversations with his mom which he
always is uh referencing but
I I need to ask him some tough straight
on questions about it and I mean
jokingly we had said you know is there
like you know who are you supporting and
he was just like no this is just
overhead costs this is what it takes to
run the business
well then your business is failing
underneath you
right yeah right and this isn't even
like a capital expense like he went and
bought a tractor for the farm this is
like pan light bills is what he's trying
to tell you is that right
yes yes
and shipping fees yeah
um yeah Insurance fees so but it didn't
add up so yeah and that that's the part
that he didn't sit down and say Here's
the receipts here's where this is at I
shouldn't have done this I screwed up
um I got all these new invoices and I
panicked and I just opened up a quick
line of credit and paid this that's not
his response his response was you're
crazy you leave me alone
all I'm doing is this right yeah it's
always been a mess yes not my fault yeah
um and
there's a reason the word we use and we
don't we're not trying to oversell it
here
um here at Ram so we use the words
Financial infidelity
because it's that level of violation
when you find out the home the the
foundation of your home that you were
walking on is is suddenly not what you
thought it was
right and right my guess here is there's
something deeper here either he feels
like he is the son that was supposed to
keep his family business going and he is
unable to live in reality that this
business isn't solvent or
um
he's seeing somebody or like and that's
the problem with lying right is it opens
up the whole every door and window in
the house for scrutiny and questions
and so uh my experience has been when I
have these type of conversations and I
haven't had to have them with my wife
but I've had to have them with
co-workers before
um
I have to write it down otherwise I get
pretty pissed off and I get pretty
emotional I get pretty fired up and then
I stop thinking and then I get
accusatory and so I would write down
here's your concerns here's your
questions
and ask him directly I need direct
answers to these questions and here's
the overarching theme I no longer feel
safe in my home I don't feel safe in my
marriage with you because you have
violated my trust we're going to start
there and you get to feel you're not
going at him you lied you did this we're
talking about here's how I feel right
now and he can't deny that
right okay if you think he needs you
need a like a marriage counselor or
somebody in your community a couple that
you trust that can sit with you guys
that's cool
um but in my if I was doing if I was in
your exact shoes I would write these
things down Rachel what do you think no
it's a great yeah a great Point yeah and
Jenny I mean like in this if I were like
if that had happens in my household
right if I'm putting myself in your
shoes
the business issues the Tactical side of
the business whether it's failing like
that's that's down the road like I'm
gonna worry about that but I think
talking to him about like the like this
is a this is a marriage issue because in
his head he probably is I would think
still uh functioning at the level of
like oh gosh you found out about the
debt and he and it's still in a money
Sphere for him possibly with the with
possibly knowing oh gosh there might
this might get worse and deeper and I
think you coming at it as like as my
husband and our marriage like forget the
quote-unquote money piece it's what John
said it's it's the lying like I you lied
to me you lied to me and here's the
facts of what I found and and we kind of
talk through this because I have to get
to a point again where where we rebuild
this trust because man this is this is
not this is not going to go well this is
not a good pattern
um and that's a and that's hard Jenny
like that's a hard conversation to have
do you guys in your marriage do you feel
um
like have y'all have y'all been able to
have like healthy conflict if you will
in marriage like do you feel like you
have a voice in the marriage all of that
or is this going to be like an out of
character thing for him to experience
yeah
and when you know you said the thing
about you know he's the son who has to
carry on the family business and feeling
that responsibility something just went
playing in my heart because he said
things like that before like he has to
keep it going well let's let's put one
up let's put one more on there
you came to him at some point a year ago
six months ago and said I'm ready to
cash in all that I've worked for to get
my high paying corporate job because
I've been feeling
that the next chapter of my life was
going to be a stay-at-home mom and he
loves you so much he's like I'm all in
and wanted to do what he could to
support your dream just that maybe the
math isn't working out and so I could
see a scenario where he started trying
to do the best he could to keep your
dream alive the households dream alive
or maybe he pressured you into quitting
your job who knows but that on top of
hey you're this you're the we picked you
Golden Boy to keep the family business
going and people do wild things when
they start feeling pressure and it may
be that this is a conversation that
he will weep from he's been carrying
this so long there will be some peace in
his soul finally you know I mean because
shame it's brene Brown says shame eats
secrets for breakfast man he's probably
dying under the weight of this thing and
again this is the best case scenario
right yeah um that he was such a good
guy he tried to find every Avenue and
ended up finding himself over his head
and then he started lying about it cool
we can work from that or worst case
scenario he's got somebody else right
and he is blowing through money left and
right who knows
um there's just not another way
um to heal from this except right
through the middle of it and I would go
in very clear what I was going to say
and go in very much here's how I'm
experiencing this not you did and you
did here's what I'm experiencing and
here's what I'm about to do about it
unless we get real clear real fast and
we'll be thinking about you if you get a
moment call us back and let us know how
things went after this conversation I'd
like to follow up with our audience on
it thank you so much for trusting us
this is the Ramsey Show we'll be right
back
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm John deloney
joined here by Rachel Cruz and we're
taking your calls Triple eight eight two
five five two two five blinds.com is 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure or pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free get
free samples free shipping and with the
new promos they run every month you'll
save even more use promo code Ramsey to
get the best deal and today's question
comes from Brenda in Missouri my husband
and I are 61 and we had a nice Nest Egg
of Investments we worked with our
financial advisor for 14 years and he
was someone that we trusted that was
trusted and did Financial seminars at
our church he ended up embezzling all of
our retirement Investments oh gosh and
is now in prison but we're left with
nothing what should we do we're scared
death oh Brenda oh my gosh
well I'm gonna assume there's there's
lawsuits and you know action that's
being taken
um
yeah the only thing I can think of is
the two examples that come to mind are
one again this is third hand but reading
some of the Bernie Madoff losses right
um and they were left with nothing and
they had to start over and then the
people that I knew
um in Houston where I grew up that were
overly if not entirely invested in Enron
and Enron went away and they woke up
they went to bed millionaires they woke
up next day with nothing with nothing
and they literally had to start over and
just had to go get
a close friend family that who I
actually love was uh executive there and
then shortly thereafter was um running a
laser tag company I mean and was going
to massage school I mean just started
over like we got to start over so
um
this is one of those hard things that
maybe you can have a loss well well I
don't yeah I don't know it's insured but
I doubt it
if you contact you know who he was Whose
license was with I mean like you know
what I mean sometimes that there's some
insurance or something it has some
things in there within yeah I mean I
would dig into that Brenda but man
just to tell you to start over at 61
breaks my heart it does it does
um
yeah it breaks my heart and there is
unfortunately my career has been
the the majority of my career has been
sitting down with folks when the worst
of the worst has happened and saying
okay this is this is reality this is
this is what has happened what are we
going to do next yeah right yeah and it
would it's maybe a hard conversation
about we got to go back to work and both
of us have to work a lot just to try to
get a little bit back in the as much as
we can back in the system so that it can
start earning and start earning yeah
um and now's a tough season
um actually now's a great season to be
throwing money in the market because
it's on sale right but
um
if this is what I think it is Brenda I I
hate to be the guy to tell you but it
looks like y'all are going to be
starting over and it may be what you
thought were the next 20 years between
61 and 81 y'all are going to be
traveling the country it may be between
61 81 y'all are working really hard um
or y'all are finding work in your local
community or maybe have to move you've
got to figure stuff out
um not by your hand but in your lap this
happened and
we're gonna have to call some old
business contacts we're gonna have to
crank up a small business we're gonna
have to get a job in a local community
and
um
just start saving again this is just
really heartbreaking Rachel do you have
any other
yeah no I mean that that would be it I
would either go you know the legal
routes and see what again where licenses
are where he's Affiliated I mean talking
to
all that but if there's not a safety net
there
and a catch-all and a yeah anything
there then starting over is is what that
that would be the case that's like yeah
so what do we do now without reality so
I'm so sorry Brenda all right let's go
to Robert in Tampa Florida hey Robert
what's up
hello how are you guys today we're great
man how are you
good deal kind of in a little bit of a
dilemma and I think I know the right
answer but my gut my heart are
differing in opinions my mind keeps
talking let me know what's so what do
you think what's up
all right so my wife and I were on steps
four five and six we clean our mess up
ten years ago after we got married we're
in a good spot a couple years ago we
decided to become foster parents we are
doing very well awesome we're stable so
we started taking in kids so as of
Monday we have three foster kids plus
our daughter everything's going smooth
we get a phone call late at night uh
they just took four kids in they need
bets just just you gotta bet so we took
two of them we took the six and the
seven year olds so now we have them in
our house we have beds and
it's a mess fostering is difficult it's
really hard especially when you first
get the kids but you know we've had them
but we're in a bit of a pickle
we want to keep them we know that if we
let these girls go they're going to
split they're going to go to two
different houses if they don't end up
like group homes or sleeping in an
office
we'd like to keep them
we don't we have one car or one car
household I work from home I don't need
a car
we don't have enough seat belts
now
from a financial perspective like more
profine right we're on baby steps four
five and six we have the emergency fund
the whole nine yards but
in order to get a car with enough seat
belts I especially we need to sell the
one we have and go buy one so we're
looking at something you know two or
three years older than what we have just
trying to make it work but when you
start getting up to an eight-seat
vehicle even 10 year old ones are kind
of expensive especially in this market
you I have to bring money to the table
and I don't have enough cash to bring to
the table to do it right now so I'd have
to dig myself like a three month old
debt
I could probably clean it up in three
months it's not that bad my gut says
stick with your discipline you're
already helping three kids like
help yourself first do it right and then
do what you can
but my heart says no keep the girls yeah
and I don't really know where I'm at
with this yeah and and for you Robert is
the is the eight seat belts the thing
that would keep you from keeping the
curls
the licensing will not let me keep them
if I don't if I can't transport them how
much do you have in your emergency fund
thirty thousand go buy a van
how much is your car worth now
probably like 15. yeah go sell it and
take 15 of that money and buy a 30 000
van to get you down the road and it's
not going to be a nice fan
and that's kind of where I'm at is like
debt has been almost sacrilegious
you don't need to Robert and let me
challenge you on this
um who you are and what you are doing
you and your wife are doing is
is second to none
like y'all y'all are you are the shiny
example of who we all could and should
be in our communities so I applaud you
and you have boxed yourself into a
corner that I think is not an accurate
representation of reality you really
want these girls you do not have a
guarantee they're going to get split up
they might
but the Children's Home that I was on
the board of for several years did EV
they fought through the nail to keep
kids together
and so you might want them and that's
how the debt that's how debt makes its
way into our lives when we really really
want something usually it's a guitar or
it's a fancy sports car and in your case
you really really want to love two young
kids incredible
um sacrificing your values and your own
mental health and your own anxiety
because now you owe somebody money you
gotta get this paid off I got seven
miles to feed I got eight miles if he
you know as well as we do that you're
gonna you're going to push a snowball
off the top of a hill it's going to go
the other way
right you're going to start a Cascade of
things that are going to be very hard to
wrap back up because you think you can
do it in three months unless one of
these kids needs has special needs
another kid has special dietary concerns
and then now we're down another road and
so I would um you know what I would do
before I did anything is I would call a
couple of friends
um I've got a couple of buddies that
I've reached out to in the past and said
hey there's somebody in need and before
I can finish the sentence they'll say
how much
and I'll send you 1500 bucks from each
of you and they've shown up every time
or call your local church and say Here's
what I'm about to do here's what I'm
facing ten thousand dollars would make a
huge difference in the lives of these
two little girls right and here's the
thing you have become the hero to a to
three kids now four and five kids
sometimes Heroes have to ask for help
and I would make a phone call to some
people in your life that you trust or to
your local congregation to see if some
people give them an opportunity to step
up too
um but man thank you for your heart just
amazing
uh Nate that's the first hour in the
books here on the Ramsey Show stay with
us we will be right back
[Music]
foreign
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio what's up it's
the Ramsay show where America hangs out
to have a conversation about your money
your life your relationships your work
your mental health all of it triple
eight eight two five five two two five
whatever's going on in your life
we'll walk alongside you hope you figure
out the next
the next right thing to do that's what
we're gonna do uh triple eight eight two
five five two two five I'm John deloney
joined here by Rachel Cruz
um an extraordinary human being and um
easily the most brilliant person at the
table and we're taking your calls on by
far everything everything all right
let's go out to Hannah in Frederick
Maryland what's up Hannah
it's a privilege to talk to you guys
I've been growing up with all the Ramsay
everything my whole life so it's just
been it's an honored to talk to you both
well it's an honor to talk to you thank
you so so much what's up
awesome so my husband and I are on baby
steps four and six and we are just
trying to figure out how best to
prioritize different house upgrades that
we want to do
um like maybe we want to add a garage
upgrade the kitchen upgrade the HVAC do
other things to it and we we just don't
know the best way to go about doing our
list of things we want to do so I was
just looking for advice on that
yeah do you guys have do you have a
budget do you have money saved do you
know what what you're gonna be working
with financially
yeah so we uh budget every month we make
uh on the lower month we make about
eight grand on a good month because my
husband also gets part commission we go
to about 11 Grand so on average we have
about 1400 to 2 Grand or a little more
extra to put toward whatever project we
want to do okay and how much you guys
have saved now
right now
yep we have 2 900 saved okay awesome
well when you're asking about
Renovations I mean this is a a large
range right you could do hey I'm going
to just paint the kitchen cabinets put
some new hardware maybe get some new you
know appliances or I had somebody come
give me a quote to do all the siding the
other day and it's very expensive right
so it ranges so yeah so it's either like
how much you want to DIY at Hannah and
kind of just say hey yeah here or versus
we're going to be tearing out walls and
changing our house you know floor plan
like I um so all of that is going to
vary in cost so for you guys I mean it's
not like you're working with forty
thousand dollars you know to go in and
do it so it's gonna probably have some
DIY aspects to it does that sound
reasonable like that you you feel like
that's a good a good approach part of it
yeah we definitely we definitely expect
we'll be doing DIY to it already we
renovated our bathroom and rent DIY the
majority of it too so we're definitely
down to do that we're just trying to
figure out like because if we want to
save up and do garage but then if say
that 50 Grand it takes us a couple years
to build up for that but then that's 50
Grand we could have put toward the house
is reducing the payment on that so we're
just oh I see okay but we could also do
that instead so yeah what's more
important for you
that's the stuff we're struggling on too
uh garage but then we look at what gets
higher in the priority list like say if
the garage is 50 Grand but that's also
50 Grand we could have put toward the
house so I guess the higher the payment
the higher it gets for the project the
more we're leaning towards let's just
get this house done and out of the way
how much
um how much you have left on the house
to pay it off uh we have 265 000. okay
um
yeah I mean if I were yeah because I
mean you're in the baby steps that like
you can you guys can enjoy some of it
right like this is yes we want you to
pay off the house early for sure
um but it's not like everything is
gazelle intense towards paying off the
house
so I would probably leave the high
ticket price items the garage things
that are like pretty pricey I personally
would probably say hey that's going to
be a dream after we pay off the house
but these smaller these smaller projects
to kind of still scratch that itch of
like we still kind of want to update the
house
um I would be okay with you doing like
you said we just you know we did a
bathroom
um I think that's great so if there's
things to the kitchen that you want to
kind of redo like I would pick Maybe
two or three projects that you guys can
kind of cash flow in the next maybe two
three years
um while also knowing how much you can
pay how quickly it's gonna take to pay
off the house because 265
000 yeah I mean that that's going to
take years
um for where you guys are at which is
totally fine but I would want if I was
your husband and I wanted the 50 000
garage
and then you're telling me I want to pay
off the house first I need to know like
when's the date that the house is going
to be paid off like give me a date and
if it and and honestly too Kelly if it
feels uh or Hannah I'm sorry if it feels
so far off like if you guys do the math
and look at the house and like oh man
we're really going to want a garage
sooner then you guys you you can like
continue to paint on the house extra but
if you wanted to keep setting some side
some aside to save up for the garage you
can do that too
okay and Hannah here's okay I'm just
thinking I'm trying to think of I want a
garage too okay
um I have it all mapped out it's gonna
have a secret tunnel that goes from the
hot the whole thing
um
and when I me and my wife sat down to
discuss like hey we've got to get a new
roof we've got that's a thing we had to
do right this air conditioner is about
to go out that's a thing we had to do
and then there's the what do you want to
do I'd love to get a big long retaining
wall here I'd love to do these things
here and it was the line I'll feel safer
when the house has paid off
that then kicked my butt into gear that
was a line that my wife used that I
don't think it was a line I think that
was her that was very true I'll feel
safer before we start spending a hundred
thousand dollars on this and 50 on this
if we don't have a mortgage
um and so over the last 24 months man
I'm taking every speaking gig I'm
traveling all over the country it
motivated me to go above and beyond and
I think that conversation with your
husband
what else can we be doing to accelerate
this house payoff and let's knock a year
off this thing we're going to be
exhausted but we're going to have no
debt and then we can build whatever we
want to does that make sense
yeah no that makes perfect sense and
that's kind of the lines we were
thinking and just trying to balance like
paying off the house quickly but also
still having fun and doing other
projects in the meantime issue yeah for
us is the hard thing is finding that
balance in this stage right now I use
real numbers and real data and go one
project at a time it's real easy these
things get very uh emotional and
overwhelming in your head that yes yes
okay so how much is the garden gonna
cost it's gonna cost three thousand
bucks let's put that money aside and
let's spend the next three months
working on again right yeah totally
project by project yes for sure for sure
so scratch the itch where you can so you
don't feel like you have to do the fifty
thousand dollar garage or again maybe
you run the numbers and it's like let's
put all this little ones aside and maybe
we pay extra in the house we pay it off
five years early and can do the garage
around the same like whatever the thing
is the combination is but I think when
you don't have a house payment though to
John's Point Anna there's just this like
oh wow we really aren't attached to
anyone all right like nothing think
about those 11 000 months suddenly your
garage takes four months to save up for
it yeah for three months that's right
that's right it goes real real fast yep
yep you don't have a mortgage or you're
not putting all of your money on top of
that triple eight eight two five five
two two five this is the Ramsay show
give us a shout we're here to talk we'll
be right back
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the Ramsey Show hey every
time you hear someone do their debt-free
Scream on the show it's because at some
point they said I've had it I'm not
living like this anymore when you get
mad like that and do what they did your
life will change too and right now
inflation and credit cards and car
payments and all this it's killing you
you've been led to believe that you're
not in control of your money and that's
wrong you have to decide to control what
you can control and that's you your
thoughts and your actions you have the
power to change your future and I know
everyone is telling you that you can't
do it you can't do it you can
and Financial Peace University will show
you how this court will this course will
teach you the proven step-by-step plan
that's helped nearly 10 million people
beat debt Master budgeting and build
wealth and you can do it too guys stop
letting debt and money stress control
your life say I've had it take back your
control start Financial Peace University
at ramseysolutions.com
FPU that's ramsesolutions.com
FPU let's go out to Kelly in Columbus
Ohio what's up Kelly
hi guys thanks so much for taking my
call you got it what's up
so first of all you're my favorite so
I'm kind of geeking right now tell Ken
and George and Dave no no don't don't
tell him
so here's my question in short Is it
wise especially now with the market to
pause on retirement 15 off our mortgage
early
um and I can kind of give you the
details we have we currently have a lot
invested
um you know I have my balance in the
mortgage should we I just want to like
the last color I just want to get it
done I would have so much peace knowing
our mortgage is paid off so we can do so
much more
um how much do you own the house
198.5 how long will that take you
so what I'm thinking is if we pause on
on the retirement we could free up about
eleven hundred dollars
um a month we my husband still wants to
keep that three percent and just so they
can continue matching it
um so if we free up 1100
um and start paying that towards it and
then in about a year and a half I'm
going to be going full time so I will be
doubling my income
um so after that time you can put up to
2500 so anywhere between 1100 or 2500 is
my goal in the next couple years I'm
thinking we can have it paid off in five
or six years if we're really intense
I wouldn't do it for five or six years
no if you told me you're gonna have it
paid off in 18 months Maybe
um okay right and right now the stock
market's on sale like this is a time to
be putting money in
because it's low right right well let me
tell you that we have currently after we
looked at it was January we have a
little over 400 000 and
um Investments
um between you know Roth IRA IRA and um
and 401k and we're 45 and 46. so you're
fine and if that changes things no it
doesn't in fact it would it causes me to
tell you not to stop retirement like
that would be even more of a reason to
continue to put it in and I hear you
Kelly like I
I I know and it's and I think one of the
best things is that you're not gonna be
touching this money for another 20 years
and the world is going to look a whole
lot different in about 15 20. we'll
we'll look different in 15 and 20 years
than it does now so I think ringing your
hands and being nervous about what the
Market's doing to long-term Investments
is doing you no good honestly and and
I'm in this stuff every day we talk
about money day in and day out and I
don't I don't know I don't look I look
once a year and I see what the Market's
doing on the news I mean I keep up with
current events of what's happening but
I'm not looking at my personal because
it probably would make me sick you're
like oh God but then I also know I still
have confidence that it's going to come
back I mean the market that you've
invested in it has a long-term track
record okay and so if you believe which
part of my conspiracy theory heart my a
little bit that like it's all we're
we're screwed and all that right but the
logical side of me is like it's not the
economy is going to come back we're
going to have you know many more
presidents in office I mean life is just
going to look different and so if I was
45 I would be putting money in
retirement while again paying off the
house it's the baby steps going back to
those basic principles but
um yeah Kelly I would continue to do
what you're doing I would still fun 15
because I'm telling you I think 60 60
year old Kelly's gonna have a paid for
house and a lot in retirement and she's
going to be happy she's gonna be good
yeah okay I know that's not what you
wanted to hear Kelly and I appreciate
your enthusiasm to get the mortgage paid
off I hear that
um yeah but the hard thing would be hey
what if you guys looked up at 60 and
thought God we could our the house has
paid off we could retire but we can't we
have to work another five years to make
sure our nest egg is big enough when you
could have been putting money away
starting now and that's what the market
is like the the compound interests and
all of I mean the money's gonna work for
you and that's what I love about
investing even though I know it's down I
hear you
um but again it's going to change long
term can I tell you something that
happens in my life Kelly and this maybe
this is yours
whenever I really really want something
I am somehow able to find proof of what
I want and why I should do it or have it
all over the place
and so whenever I look at the track
record of the last hundred years which
is I mean so I got
um
it the data shows that after a recession
a big one a small one the market comes
roaring back and it is roaring back up
at a pretty significant clip
when I really really want to do
something with my house
um I'm able to talk myself into at some
point it all comes down at some point it
all just didn't pull it right and I can
spin myself up and make make withdrawing
all of my money from the market the
single most rational act I do in a day
right and so I'm with Rachel I I looked
at it for the first time like in two or
three years the other day and my
um smart investor Pro he's a buddy of
mine and all I did is I looked at it and
I was like whoa and I texted him and I
was like bang up job you're doing the
market and and he you know he wrote me
back I told you don't open that right
because I'm irrational and so I've
already made the decision the long-term
decision I'm never gonna oh I'm not
gonna pull money out of this thing
and as my friend my friend Todd uh who's
one of my best friends on planet and
he's a finance guy and he said John I
don't have a meteorite plan I don't have
a plan for if the whole monetary system
implodes and collapses because at that
point we're shooting our house with all
my water and like yes I'm just kidding
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
storm Rachel's house and steal all her
canned goods right so that's what we're
doing if that moment comes I'm gonna
deal with that moment when it gets here
all right I'm gonna spend most of my
energy living in the present I know and
that's right when I go down things
that I do think okay literally if the if
the dollar collapses and everything I'm
not even going to be looking like here
take take gold I need gold I'm gonna be
like where's bread give me give me food
and give me bottles of water here's my
we're all it's all off somebody said he
goes we have a bad habit of looking at
Future Calamity through our current he's
like you're not gonna be driving to work
right and you're not gonna be trading
coffee and bullets for gas so you can
get to your job in the air conditioning
he's like you're going to be fighting
your neighbor to not shoot your dog for
food and I remember that was the line I
was like oh yeah if it melts down if the
world goes down it melts down so like
could that happen yep and here's
this one it's gonna be like survival
that's right so I know and that was made
for that time I'm ready for it John
if I were to line up all of my closest
friends and thought and put them in
order of who could survive that you
would not be at the top not me at the
top like
gloss is gonna
run
that is not the case that is that is not
the case I will be the connector of The
Villages that I have to be like here you
know Franklin Brentwood Tennessee you're
gonna bring them together we used to be
able to get to each other in 15 minutes
now we have to walk and I can be the
connector I will do you do a lot of
connecting in your in your in your
regular life
yeah I just feel like that's what I'm
good at oh I see because some on the
internets would suggest we are highly
divisive but when it when it all goes
down we're going to flip the switch and
Rachel's gonna bring us together that's
awesome so Kelly
just keep on investing that's the moral
of the story right I mean Kelly is all
of us right all of us who's looking at
the news he's terrified of the state of
things and some people doesn't get you
it gets you nowhere you make bad
decisions when you're fearful so I got a
buddy that I call that's why people call
us right like hey I'm about to make a
dumb decision and they go don't do that
right because we don't make good
decisions when we're scared so thanks
for trusting us Kelly uh I hate to be
the one to burst your bubble but
stand the plan stay on the plan we'll be
right back
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
foreign
[Music]
Oregon and talk to Travis what's up
Travis
how you doing sir man first I just want
to thank you so much for your time and I
have the most respect for you so thank
you guys very much for taking my
question you got it y'all got a big
election happening right now huh are
coming up
yeah for sure I try to stay away from
the news because it gives me a headache
dude this is what mental Wellness looks
like with a good trip so what's up
brother how can we help
thank you so uh my wife and I are on
baby step two uh we started out with 102
639 uh dollars in debt and that was car
loans student loans things like that uh
we're down to 27 000 now wow great job
yes thank you and uh we we had something
happen in our family and uh due to that
I made a emotional purchase which I'm
sure you guys have heard about before
um and I just kind of want to know what
you guys think I should do from here
sure I've I've never personally made one
of those ever
geez like I think I did yesterday
um what happened man
um so uh we have uh
two beautiful daughters and a son
um and then uh 2020 in the beginning of
2020 uh my wife was pregnant uh with her
first son and we began to have some
pregnancy complications she went on bed
rest for six weeks and uh he was born in
April of 2020 uh and unfortunately did
not survive and it was the hardest thing
my wife and I have ever gone to yeah
no I'm so sorry man
thank you and I'll just get to the
question part um
you do that it just kind of made me
think about
not being guaranteed and memories not
being guaranteed and one thing I really
wanted to do with my son was camp and
things like that so I purchased the
camper for seventeen thousand dollars
I'm sorry for being emotional no dude
you have to apologize to us for two
parents too man we're emotional with you
brother take your time man
that's pretty much my question I I'm not
alone for 17 grand so I know I'm kind of
going backwards on my baby step
um when did you when did you buy this
camper brother
ah like three months ago okay oh so just
recently
yeah okay so you sat
um you've been y'all been picking up the
pieces for the last 18 months or so
I'm sorry say that again sir you all
have been picking up the pieces and
figuring out what's next oh yeah the
past 18 months two years yeah okay
yeah and we're doing financially great
you know so that's not an issue I just
kind of was like being impatient I guess
and kind of going back to like I just
don't know what's going to happen
tomorrow and I and I'm kind of fearful
of the future now
um that's why I didn't know because I
just don't know what's gonna happen you
know that's kind of why I did it my
rationale yeah
um
so I'll say this I don't blame you for a
second and I get your your heart is good
and your impulses I get them
um I would tell you this is one of the
great benefits of a plan this is one of
the great benefits of having people that
you trust
when we are deep in grief or we find
ourselves telling ourselves stories
about tomorrow
um
man our bodies get spun up and we start
trying to solve problems
um in in immediate ways that aren't
always the wisest long term and so
you've bought it how long is going to
take you to pay it off
uh
we I could probably pay it off in a
couple years if I was hard at it or even
less we do okay financially okay
um I just camped out the other night
with my son in a tent
um and so I it sounds like you boxed
yourself into a
um
it's gonna be this or it's going to be
nothing if I don't do this now I'm going
to miss out on more time with my other
two kids
um are my other three kids and you've
created a narrative that somehow the
lack of time you got to spend with the
other child was your fault you've
created a narrative that it's all gonna
it's all gonna be it's all a vapor and
it is but it's just not a vapor tomorrow
um be honest with me would you be at
more at peace with yourself if you sold
this camper you took a lump because
you're gonna You Know You're Gonna Lose
a little money on it would you feel
better getting back on track
yeah I think the idea I don't want to
agree with you but you're probably right
no I'm I'm asking you I'm not telling
you this is what you should feel I'm
asking you
um
i i i i i impulse
this is a shame to say this I I we have
a the Battle of the Bands event here and
the other day I was visiting a friend at
a guitar shop and I impulse and
purchased a guitar that
I for one night of 15 minutes right it
was ridiculous and then I had to cash
forward it was budget is fine
but I feel guilty over that I'm like
what are you doing man what a dummy you
know what I mean that's that's just my
self-talk to myself
um I would be more at peace if I didn't
have that right now the show would have
been just fine without it you get what
I'm saying
yeah I do Travis how much do you guys
make a year
uh we're at 96 right now you're at 96.
okay the 27 000 in debt that you're
talking about does that include the 17
000 of the campers in addition to
44
000 if you keep the camper it's not a
I mean ideally you wouldn't take on the
extra debt and so I would if I were you
Travis I would run some numbers and just
see okay what if I did sell it today
what kind of hit do I take how quickly
would we be able to get out of debt with
the other 27 000 like I would just I
would run some scenarios run a scenario
where you sell it and how quickly you
guys can get out of debt and talk
through that kind of live in that moment
if you can
say okay how would that feel yeah and
then run another scenario where you keep
it because it's it's not you know you
make 96 it's not like it's a 80 000 you
know run a scenario where you pay it off
keep it and pay it off and see how long
that takes you and talk to your wife and
say okay how does that feel so
the goal for us on the show is is to
become as to become debt free as quickly
as possible not just for the financial
sake even though there's a lot of
benefits to that when you keep your
income you're able to save more and give
more and invest more but there's an
emotional piece to Travis to that that
when you
don't owe anyone anything John talks
about this there's a there's a safety
that happens even in your brain like you
you know I am I'm safe because I'm not
attached to something I don't owe
someone something and there's a level of
peace and a level of rest you get when
you don't when you're not a slave to the
lender right the borrower's slave to
lenders what proverb says and that
there's there's truth to that and so
that's one of the benefits of getting
out of debt yes the financial piece is
huge but there's also an emotional piece
and you guys are going through a lot of
emotional pieces in your life
um
since since losing your son and so to me
there's almost this burden that gets
lifted off it's one last thing I have to
worry about as we continue to grieve
what happened to us two years ago so
almost as a mom I want least the least
amount attached to me on things that I
don't really need in my life to just
have the weights off of it does that
make sense the lighter I can be in life
that's what I'm looking for and that's
completely on an emotional sense and I'm
not the doctor John can speak and if
that's correct or not but like that's
how I would feel I think so so talk
through that with your wife you know
what I mean like the camper you know
love it hate it sure you you bought it
maybe an emotional purchase give
yourself Grace that's okay that's okay
like just just give yourself some some
some Grace because you guys have been
walking through a lot of hard stuff but
I think that there is you know some
decisions that could be made here in the
next month to say hey what what can we
do to get us further where we want to be
and so
um another another thing to remember
Travis do is that this isn't the only
camper right like if you guys decided to
sell it
in in four years you can buy something
awesome and continue it you know so
um just just some things to think
through I don't want to give you just
like a hard fast thing if I were you I'd
probably sell it because I would want to
be out of debt as quickly as possible
um and that's you know that and that's
what we talk about on this show and you
called us so we're going to give you
that and Travis let me tell you this
yeah
um we often as as adults we think of
parenting
as these big flag in the ground moments
what our kids talk about at our funerals
is the way we made them feel every day
when they got home from school
they remember the times we were being
goofy in the car on the way to church
every Sunday they might remember a trip
here or there they might remember the
funny camping thing but they'll remember
dad always included us and stuff and so
don't think that you're parenting that
your memories are wrapped up in these
big things we've got to go on a camper
we gotta go man 10 out in the backyard a
few nights your kids will remember that
we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
for a minute about how much there is so
much fear in the media right now you
turn on the TV you open social media you
hang out with Rachel Cruz it's
everywhere
but here's the thing there is still hope
it's still possible to get out of debt
and it's still possible hold your hats
boys and girls it's still possible to
build wealth right now our Building
Wealth live events walk you through a
simple but proven plan that will help
you save money build wealth and make
smart decisions in this Bonkers economy
it is possible join me Dave Ramsey
Rachel Cruz Ken Coleman and George
Campbell for a night of Hope and
normalcy this spring
will be in Indianapolis on February 16th
in Austin Texas February 23rd and in
Anaheim on May 2nd tickets start at 39
bucks and listen our fall event sold out
in days so you don't want to wait we've
already met people here today in the
lobby that have already bought their
tickets from for some of these shows
visit ramseysolutions.com events to get
your seats today all right let's go to
Lisa in Newport Washington what's up
Lisa
hey hey I have a question about taking
money out of 401k my husband had a job
for about 25 years got laid off during
covid uh got two years School paid for
we were able to make it through the two
years without going into debt we only
have a mortgage we have about 40 000 of
the emergency funds but we want to pay
off the house because now he got hired
by his interning but we're only making
what we've been cut 40 to 50 percent of
our income and we've adopted six kids so
we're old but we have
a six to seven and eight-year-old so we
still have a long way to go but with
money getting so tight
I'm getting a little uh concerned with
you know being or not losing our house
and we still have six kids to raise
we've already raised our older four
um and so okay to talk to you suggest
yeah talk me through
um Lisa you said that that you're was it
your pay was cut in half your time for
work was cut in half
so he was laid off
um because of covid yeah and he was
there probably 24 or 25 years
and the company is closed okay and so
they because of the layoff they did pay
for two years of school
and so he finished school in two years
and we were able to do that without any
debts
um unemployment we we cinched our bills
we're pretty we know how to squeeze a
penny
um
and so now we
the job market is
probably about 60 of what we were making
and before he had so much overtime that
we don't have that anymore okay what
does he do Lisa
Machinist
okay and what did he go to school for
he actually got a higher degree in the
Machining because because we're so we're
older we're in our mid 50s
to start something new he wanted to
monopolize on what he on his experience
already okay and machining was out there
but then he learned the computer part of
it but the the skill he went to school
and learned is worth 60 is worth half of
what his skill was before he got
educated right now
yeah the the he had an internship and
they hired him and they said well this
is all we can pay you and so
he wants to finish the year out with his
commitment and then we need to start
looking for a different a better job but
yes because this sounds like a guy who
got hit in the mouth by
a company that he dedicated a quarter of
his life to
and that he gave everything to and then
he found out the hard thing that
millions and millions of people found
out that he got up went to work one day
and he found out oh this thing's a vapor
it's gone I'm Expendable and that has
um
the the psychological research suggests
that that is as damaging as losing a
spouse as losing a family member
um yeah and to come back and take
whatever somebody says he's worth that
is 60 here's the deal one is that 60 of
what he was making
but two it's not enough to keep his
house afloat
right and so it's not tenable and I know
he wants to keep his commitment and he
wants to do these things it just doesn't
I don't know man it feels like a mess
yeah I mean I mean well I mean when you
look at money Lisa it flows two ways
right it flows in and it flows out so
those are the two ends of the equation
that you can control
and the money flowing in yeah is is
almost cut in half like what you were
saying and so I would I would question
okay what else is out there with his
experience what he's done the line of
work that he's been in I mean he's he he
is marketable uh I understand it may not
be exactly what he's been doing but I
would look to see if there's any other
job because at this point yeah you're
you have to pay your bills right so
bringing in that money and the other
side is the expenses so do you guys have
do you guys have a lot of Consumer Debt
where are you guys at financially
we have no debt other than just our
mortgage and
um and we have we luckily we had
emergency funds oh 40 000 right yes and
we still have we still have that cash 40
000 emergency fund I did take it was at
50 but I took about 10 because I I'm
trying my goal is to have the house paid
off
um in 2024 but then two years hit us so
tridentality is working trying to at
least
I do a few things extra and I'll put
some money or you know I'm trying to
still
punch down that principle because we owe
130
138 actually on the house okay and
what's he making now with the lower
salary
um he's probably making
around 50 55. and at times with overtime
we were actually up to about a hundred
yeah he might have to
go work overtime at a second job
yeah
um yeah well we have really difficult we
we adopted really difficult kids and his
presence is pretty necessary I get that
but listen Lisa you've created a world
that math can't support
yeah you'll adopted six kids because you
all have hearts of gold you're great
human beings and you've paid off your
house like crazy yourself out of debt
because y'all are disappointed and done
hard work and then life happened
and so we're not our house is not paid
off yet I I know but y'all are working
really really hard
right and then he went and got educated
to get an even better job and then went
and took the first one he could get at
half of what he was previously valued
before he was educated and so
and he worked a lot of overtime and now
we want him at home here's what you have
to Something's Gonna Give
something's going to have to give and
Rachel and I have taken too many calls
over the years where the thing that gave
was the mortgage they came and took your
house the thing that gave was somebody's
health
and so
at some point I just don't have a really
hard conversation I know you want to
live right ride the year out we can't
afford for you to ride the year out I
really really need you here but what I
needed more is not the electric and gas
not to get shut off
right now you know I mean so I need you
you're gonna have to get a second job
and you're 50 something years old we
didn't have this drawn up this way
sitting how we drew it up this is when
the house was going to be paid off we're
gonna be living our life and here we are
right we have to acknowledge and own
reality before we and also Lisa I don't
want this to be your reality for the
next seven years either and so there has
to be a change either with his full-time
job
or your situation I mean if it's
something as drastic as as downsizing a
home so that you can the bills can be
manageable with his salary like there
has to be a give somewhere and to answer
your original question no don't borrow
from your future to keep yourself afloat
today
have the hard yeah the hard life change
don't don't don't don't if you pull
money out right now with this down as
the market is you are locking in Forever
those losses don't do it don't do it
don't do it don't do it would you take
that emergency fund down to the original
start over start over in baby steps and
punch it into the more well I I wouldn't
Lisa just because of I want you because
it's not sustainable yeah it once that
money's gone it's gone and you're and
nothing else has changed so other things
need to change besides the emergency
fund it's there if you the safety net of
oh God like we really can't believe this
blows off yes that we that we have it
there but I don't want that to be a
bucket that you dip out of your for your
lifestyle choices or your lifestyle
expenses I should say
um so I would do whatever I can on that
income and expenses side of the equation
something has to give like John said
um because once that 40 000 runs out
what are you gonna do then then you're
in a big mess so no keep that safety net
afloat and find other ways where you can
cut or bring in more money I'm sorry
what you guys are doing incredible
incredible work though with these six
kids so and you have to just live with
math because it doesn't change thank you
so much for loving your community
thank you thank you this is another hour
in the books we'll be right back on the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's John deloney co-host of the
Ramsey show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the Ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio what has
happened in America it's the Ramsay show
we're hanging out to have a conversation
about your life your mental health your
relationships your work and your money
I'm John deloney joined here by one of
the greatest people you will ever know
Rachel Cruz and we are taking your calls
live triple eight eight two five five
two two five it's triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's go out to
Gretel in Fargo North Dakota what's up
Gretel
hi good afternoon everyone good
afternoon to you what's happening
well
um I get married to
um a guy who got divorced and it was
um well the divorce was fine but we
found out that I found out right after I
got married to him that in the divorce
paper had to be so unfair with all the
deaths that she put in towards my
husband's name which he didn't know and
um what he agreed with it just for peace
and stuff and like the student loan they
made together during their marriage was
put on all to his name and for the past
five years we've had quite problems with
every year uh she is homeschooling the
boys and she wants us to help with
homeschooling well as far as I know and
what is written in
um
in the divorce or like like generally
child support should cover education and
other stuff and that's what in the
course them in Minnesota says and
um
but now
we I
me and my husband decided that we should
not help her with the finances like she
wants us to pay 200 a month toward
homeschooling and I told my husband that
instead of putting it in
um cash then let's put it towards the
boys like we spend more time with them
so we could have more time because we
see them hardly ever at all and even
though in a divorce paper it's just
supposed to say every weekend but she's
taking them most of the time so I said
instead of that money giving towards her
well she had the the divorce paper had
been unfair so it's just fair enough
that we both put
um the money instead towards seeing the
boys and then she could
um like
with
um
what is that like food and stuff yeah
Gretel what's your question
yeah the question is
um is it are we morally obliged to fund
this woman like is it okay to
financially support him her because her
she is in financial struggle right now
okay and to me yeah so first
um we're going to follow the divorce
decree
and what the divorce decree tells us to
sin we're going to send you as the new
wife
can look at the divorce decree that your
grown-up husband signed and say this
wasn't fair but you choosing to waste
one second of energy being upset about
that is a choice you are making to be
miserable don't do that yeah you married
in it's what is and we're going to pay
it off because that's what we all agreed
on in court or that's what he agreed on
yeah we paid off we paid
um I I am way more
I'm way more concerned
when I'm thinking about the the health
and wellness of these kids
outside of the four walls I'm way more
concerned
that when they're 14 15 17 18 one of
them is going to look their father in
the eye and say hey the court said you
could visit me every weekend
why didn't you fight for me
and so that's the thing no no that's a
choice y'all make
and no I would not be I would not do
things above and beyond the court order
unless we sat down as three adults or if
she's remarried and agreed on hey
there's been some different needs and if
we can be adults about it great and if
we can't then we'll we'll go back to
court and see what we need to do but
um no somebody can't just say hey by the
way I decided to do a new thing you got
to give me more money that's not how
that works that's why the court has a
decree that everybody agrees to and
everybody follows
um if your kids are suddenly unsafe or
your husband's kids are unsafe they are
in a home where they're not eating
there's not heat there's not basic
necessities
then you all have to step in and you
probably have to get an attorney to help
you with that and this isn't about
winning and this isn't about punishing
or this is about taking care of those
kids
um and I'm saying she's in financial
straights and needs to start charging
you guys for 200 every month for
homeschool it doesn't make any sense to
me but here's what I want to do I want
to start this whole conversation by
we're going to follow the divorce decree
we're going to follow what the thing
says I'm gonna go get my kids every
single weekend and if you don't want to
give me my kids then I'm gonna take you
to court because those are my children
and I'm going to see my kids I'm going
to pay the child support every single
month as written I'm gonna take care of
it if you come to me as an adult and say
hey there's some specific needs and
here's it but you getting 200 here we're
going to put in this account over here
and we're gonna do it for that just
makes this whole thing a mess don't do
that follow the plan as it's written
first let's do the basics and then if
y'all want to have adult conversations
about specific needs beyond that and
y'all can all three agree to be adults
cool and if you can't great then let's
move on
through your experience John working
with families Blended Families how what
percentage and I guess that that doesn't
matter what qualities do people have
that make this kind of situation like
really good for the kids versus putting
them in the in the middle and it's and
it you know destroys them like what
what's the like what are the things that
that she Gretel and her husband things
that they can be doing for themselves to
grow and say hey we want to become
healthier for this situation what are
those characteristics that you see
within families that do it really well
almost without exception they are they
choose we're going to be very
adult-minded about this and every bit of
our energy can be focused on what's the
greatest environment we can make for
these children and that means I'm going
to put down my jealousy every time I see
her with her new husband I'm gonna put
down my insta rage that comes over me
every time I see him with that woman he
cheated with me on now they're married
because going to war after court going
to war during court it's it helps nobody
and then this situation What's Happening
Here is these children are becoming
pawns it's a way for potentially for
ex-wife to get some more money yeah it's
a way for them to she's not following
this so I'm gonna do that you cannot use
your kids as Weapons you can't you can't
you can't you can't
um I have been astounded over
the last I don't know 15 20 years
watching adults be adults like I've
learned from watching divorced couples
say yeah I mean we were married and we
were in love and we had plans and didn't
work out and we have three kids and so
we meet every month to talk about what's
going on in our life we're able to be
civil at child conferences we all show
up because we're grown-ups yep and we
are sad in the car but we're adults and
dude it's beautiful when people choose
to put maturity above
but I want in the moment yes so be
adults everybody be adults we'll be
right back
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey this is the Ramsey Show I'm John
deloney joined here by Rachel Cruz it
really helps us out you don't have to
buy anything it takes 13 seconds if you
will do us a huge favor share the show
and yes it is self-serving it helps our
ratings and all that if you leave a
five-star review if you just hit the
Subscribe button but here's why I'm
asking you to do that
it kicks up the show in the algorithms
and it puts the show it puts specific
calls it puts debt-free screams it puts
those moments that people are craving
those those moments that can push
somebody over the edge and say now is
the time to change my life it will put
it in their podcast feed if we get more
five star reviews it puts it in on
YouTube on their YouTube channel it
kicks it up more if you will go
subscribe so it's a it's a low it's a
no-cost way to support the show but more
importantly to help put this show in
front of other people who need it the
life-changing advice the life-changing
plans that we that we offer folks thank
you so much for being with us and thank
you for helping out your your neighbor
um by leaving review positive reviews
and by hitting the Subscribe button
wherever you consume this show all right
let's go to Cameron in H-Town go stros
what's up Cameron
it's a little uh thanks for having me
I'm 62 years old I was fortunate to
retire two years ago in that time I gave
uh my two adult daughters 60 Grand a
piece to buy houses so they're set wow
that's 450 in that IRA
I have a paid off house it was about 250
they have two new vehicles and
everything's paid for uh the IRA my wife
is beneficiary the house is in both my
wife and my name and cars are about our
name do I need a wall just yet I'm
thinking I can wait till one of us are
gone and then line it up but the way
things are set up right now you can
I feel if I go she gets everything
um I think you needed a will 25 years
ago
and here's where I'm coming from on that
um
one I was the dean of students at a law
school for about for five or six years I
forgot about five years and I got to see
have a ringside seat too
what happens in Probate Court what
happens when
um relatives come out of the woods when
kids sue their parents when cousins sue
their their their aunts it's Madness
and so you have man you have done an
incredible job financially
um here's the second thing I have spent
a chunk of my career
doing death notifications showing up
with police officers in the middle of
the night when somebody's lost their
spouse somebody's lost a child
and
the number of times I've had a spouse
look at me and say I don't know what to
do next
I don't know where stuff is I don't know
where the paper is I don't know where
this is I don't know who to call and a
will helps consolidate all of that
information into a single place
and it also you have conversations about
what do you want your funeral to look
like where do you want to be buried what
do you want these things and those are
not pleasant conversations they're not
fun we've had them so many times in my
house now it's just become routine
um but it's absolutely absolutely
absolutely it gives the executor of the
will if you were to pass away tomorrow
and your wife is grieving like she's
going to and doesn't know what day it is
it gives the people in that you care
about in your life an opportunity to
walk in and say okay here's what happens
first here's what happens second here's
what happens third it helps direct the
courts it's just it just cleans it just
makes it all easier yeah okay and
Cameron and God forbid something
happened to you and your wife together
right you would probably want this stuff
to be past your kids right at that point
so it just gives
um it just gives Direction and it takes
out a lot of the hoops and stuff that
people have to jump through
um with your assets and so it just it
makes it smoother and two camera they're
not that expensive you can get you know
State specific Wills Mama Bear legal
forms is a great website you can do an
online form especially if it's not a
complicated estate you can just do a
will online
um you know pay some money and and it's
done like it's not that expensive that's
what I did mine Karen I did mine with
Mama Bear legal forms it's a simple will
I just don't have a lot
um and it's straightforward just very
similar to your situation except you get
way more money than me it's it's just
straight across the board and it's
simple and it just says it goes to here
[Music]
sir
get it notarized do it online and get it
notarized or do I go just just go to
Mama bearlegalforums.com and and um
follow the follow the process there and
I'll just walk you right through it
um or if you've got a a buddy who's an
attorney at your local church and they
can work I mean there's there's a bunch
of ways to do it I did it with mama bear
um because it's an app it's a sponsor on
the show
um it's a group that we've had a
relationship with a long time and they
make it very easy
so easy I've had a super complex will
with seven different parts and all that
this one was very simple and
straightforward and that's why I went
with it my wife did it too yep so just
yeah follow that they direct you
basically hold your hand through this
process because it because it's a weird
process creating your will and all that
um but Cameron you've done you've done a
fabulous job
um and this just is one of those safety
net things that's just really wise so
yeah it's something that we all we tell
people all the time it's stuff you don't
want to think about but life insurance
and a will are two things and you need
life insurance if someone is dependent
upon your income you would need not you
need life insurance even you
stay-at-home moms out there you need
life insurance on you because something
happens to you
then Dad has to sit there and say okay
who's going to help with the kids how
how we're going to keep life afloat and
so man that is the one thing like if
anyone if if everyone out there could
have term life insurance we've heard
just the horror stories on this show of
people that pass on Sudden things and
and then the spouse is you know has
nothing and they have to go and go back
to work maybe plug back in when they
weren't I mean it's just it's
heartbreaking in the midst of like a
really really hard time so term life
insurance our friends at Xander
recommend them
um and getting that and everyone needs a
will a will a will because again it's
it's not that expensive and it just
makes all of this so much easier when
you have a legal document that's here's
where everything is it just makes it it
makes it smoother and I'll I'll take it
one step further Cameron
um if you haven't already you sound like
somebody that probably has already done
this but for everybody listening
keep that's something that you update
once a month once every three or four
months once a quarter
um and I'm behind on mine so I gotta go
do it keep on a single piece of paper
somewhere where everyone in your home
knows where it is
all of your passwords where the bank
account is where the information is so
that if something have who to call so if
something happens to you
there's it's as easy as possible here's
what we're going for a hundred percent
of US pass away Rachel what we're going
for is can I set my wife up in a
situation where when I go
she has the blessing to just spend some
time grieving she doesn't have to spend
time wondering how she's going to eat
she doesn't have to spend time with her
insurance agents
it's all right here and she gets the
blessing and privilege of just being sad
for a long time and that's what we're
going for here and you know what John
it's fun honey I'm in my mid-30s so both
of our Winston's parents and my parents
both active you know working living life
it's great both which Applause to them
have set us all down as separate
families right we have with the Ramses
and then the Cruises have done the same
with us
um and Winston's parents every other
year they sit down with the grown kids
and they say hey here and his dad does
that he hands over a sheet of paper and
it's everyone imaginable
and then he has another list of of the
financial I mean they are so open
because it's like and then and then we
go through scenarios if something
happens to me if something happens you
know to my mother-in-law if something
both happens here's and and who's on the
who yes I mean it's all right there and
then the Ramses we've done the same
thing we do it once a year and it's like
and as a and as an adult child I'm so
thankful so all of you in your 60s and
70s who have adult children have these
conversations and I know it's awkward
it's weird
it's terrible the Ramses we've done it
for so long and we call it the when Dave
dies meeting
that was a homicide detective he's like
hey I'm gonna die so here's the so at
our house I've had I've had to be
careful that not every family talks like
we do I know but but last Christmas my
dad
brought the updated will in an envelope
and he goes hey this is where this is
this is it was like a Christmas present
and it was a Christmas present it really
I mean we joke about it but y'all in a
time of Crisis like parents that do this
and have these conversations and plan it
is it really is and for you parents who
are 60 70 50s I promise you when you
have all this written down you will
sleep a little bit deeper because you
you've thought it through you know where
it all is you'll be good to go this is
the Ramsey Show we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five
um Rachel one of the great cautions for
people who are on radio who do podcast
with media is whatever happens
don't get yourself canceled oh yeah and
John's I'm about to get myself canceled
oh my gosh okay so the other day I
posted on social media I don't even have
Mike I've got them stuff from it of
course you ready yes all right here's
what here's America here's what I posted
it's a text post on Instagram so there's
no pictures or anything no pictures just
like a black square with white fonts you
ready parents make no mistake Youth
Travel sports are for you not your kids
if athletic achievement is their only
way to connect with you they will give
up every weekend of their childhood
chasing a little ball to win your love
do what you're going to do that's fine
just be honest about the real
beneficiary
so then you said quick edit the bottom
okay hold on I'll tell you about that
okay okay so I posted that that is a
that is a freaking like
black and white statement though it is
it is and make no mistake Youth Travel
sports are for you like there's you gave
no like possibly two percent the kid
loves it right like you went hard and
all my opinions
and in the in the in the post itself I
said hey this is my working hypothesis I
think I'm right but I'd love to hear
from you and did you hear from them two
hours I lost 1 500 followers just forget
this guy
um hundreds of opinions come came flying
in which is what I asked for I loved it
yeah and one of the most common
statements early on was oh this is one
of those guys that's never done sports
or spoken like a true non-sport guy so I
did something I almost never do hey I
read the comments I never did that and I
did this time and B I actually plugged
back in and said just in case you're
wondering I played travel baseball
before it was travel baseball back when
it was we were traveling all over with
all-star teams and stuff I was pretty
good then I was a two-year multi-sport
starter in high school at Varsity
starter in high school and then I went
to college on a scholarship on an
athletic scholarship and then after
college I was running around with it
getting my head kicked in with a
professional MMA team so I spent my
whole life doing this okay and yes I've
got two little kids now and the Machine
was kicking up and I started asking
myself
a this is way different than when I was
involved oh man as I went down the
rabbit hole
good God Almighty look at this
national uh nationally visitor spending
associated with sporting events which
consists primarily of Youth and amateur
sports tournaments reached roughly 92
billion dollars
in the most recent data available
92 billion dollars it is a
multi-multi-multi multi-billion dollar
industry so here's what can I throw
another step because here's what's crazy
so the typical parent spend 693 dollars
per per child per year
so 700 now if you go into the travel
world
frequently as frequently you can spend
up to 12
000 per year with that money going
towards travel and team fees
according to a survey by project play
again the average Sports out there is
693 dollars but parents spend on excess
twelve thousand dollars for travel and
that does not include private training
clinics or sports summer camps which
also can cost hundreds to thousands of
dollars even more per year and so I this
conversation started about a decade ago
when I was working in higher ed and I
was meeting with my friends were
athletic trainers in the number of
athletic trainers saying hey we're
starting to see joint injury usage
injuries that we have normally only been
reserved for the elderly
oh 18 year olds who have been playing
not only just baseball since they were
five but a particular position that they
went and got a special coach for and
special this and special that and they
play on this team and this team in this
team and they've done the same
repetitive motion for the last 16 years
during some of the most critically
developmental critical developmental
moments of their life and their
shoulders look like the shoulders of 80
year olds and so I started thinking whoa
that doesn't sound right
um and so man if you go down the rabbit
hole the scholarship yeah oh go ahead
yeah yeah the links between travel
Sports and professional sports is
virtually zero yeah right
um the psychological challenge that's
what I'm saying yeah yes the
psychological challenges the social
isolation the travel the altered
relationship with families the research
is starting to come out saying whoa whoa
whoa what are we doing what are we doing
and so I started asking myself
why are we doing this because I want my
kids to play sports because I feel like
I got a lot from them I learned
discipline I learned how to fail in
public I learned all these great things
but to the tune of every weekend of our
family right to the tune of we're paying
off debt yet we're spending 12 Grand per
kid to play tennis to play hockey to go
on all these soccer tournaments right
and the most common feedback I get is is
twofold number one my kid loves it and
here's my response to that here's my
response to that my I woke up this
morning and shoot my wife's out of town
and so it was just me and Josephine my
six-year-old she asked me right when she
woke up stumbles in gives me her morning
hug and says can I have ice cream she
loves it she loves it can I have ice
cream for breakfast no Josephine can I
ask you oh I know can I have pancakes
and you tell it's my job as a parent to
say hey I know you love this and
if you miss every weekend what happens
to your academics if you are only with
this group of 12 people in this group
forever yes you make some deep
relationships but you miss a whole
Cascade of people that are different
than you that think different that
worship differently that's a great point
because that was going to be my feedback
to you of like yeah but what if the
kid's so good and they love it but
you're still the parent like you're the
parents I love it they oh yeah because
my kid would eat ice cream every step of
the way so the financial the financial
piece I never like to say I would never
spend x amount on a car I would never
spend that much for a vacation right
because you it's all percentages it's
all percentages so for some families 12
000 people there are some families that
are going into debt they are or they're
not doing things that they otherwise
would be would benefit their financial
positions it would help their family out
in general yes and so it's become a
detriment financially to me that's a
hard stop it's like you like we're never
on the show gonna going to say go into
debt for things so like right if you're
digging yourself in a financial hole for
this it's not smart it's not wise long
term for yourself for your family it's
not wise now if it's a small percentage
of your income knock your lights up man
do your thing if you yeah right it's not
a moral thing based on the money but I
but I would caution I'm like but there
here's here's my thing can I tell you
mine we have three kids okay our oldest
is in second grade and I have had I've
had probably five conversations I'd say
in the last like six months I don't want
to be a dramatic here I was gonna say
like it last week but it's probably been
over the six months that you know you're
talking to a parent it's like yeah we're
gonna put her in dance
and we have to do the dance
Championship League where they go and
travel because if she can't she doesn't
do that she's not gonna make Middle
School dance team because Middle School
Dance seems to be full of girls that
have been dancing right I'm using this
as an example and then if you make if
you don't make Middle School there's no
way you're gonna make high school if you
don't make high school they're going to
do drugs and they're going to die
because they're not going to be able to
but you plug in you plug in any other
sport right whether it's soccer baseball
so John honestly as a parent though in
our County in that in Nashville it's
probably very heightened too I feel like
I feel like most everyone does travel
Sports it's rare to meet a family that
doesn't and in this I mean seriously
it's crazy everyone does so I even went
down that rabbit hole where I was like
oh my gosh okay here's is this is this
gonna be bad here's the data this is
from a study here
um done in 2016.
there were 322 athletes invited to the
2015 National Football League scouting
combine 80 percent 87 percent of whom
played multiple Sports in high school
and 13 only who only play football
and what this goes on to say is the
greatest gift you can give your kids is
to let them play a bunch of different
things and let them have fun and
naturally gravitate towards a thing with
specialization happening later on in
high school and into college okay but
what if they don't make the but what if
that's a reality though
play sixth grade soccer here's why if
they're athletic they're gonna be
athletic well
if they're LeBron James you'll know at
about age six right everyone around that
kid he signed his high school in high
school he said his his tennis shoe deal
right right and there's always the story
of Rudy yes we know that there's the
story of Rudy for most of us the anxiety
intention and expense and frenetic
schedules yeah cause more challenge to
our kids than
they're good at soccer
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
ERS let's go out to uh Hector and Tampa
Florida what's up Hector
hey John hey Rachel um my wife and I
have a question we're not sure what to
do I'll give you guys our numbers and
then ask my question cool
um we earned a combined 145 000 a year
we have a main property which we live um
which we owe 266 000 it's worth about
525. we have a rental property that we
owe 50 000 and it's worth about two
hundred thousand and we have a property
uh just a bare ground
um it's free and clear it's worth about
forty thousand we have eighteen thousand
dollars in debt and seventy five
thousand dollars in savings we're not
sure if we should sell the rental and
the land and use some savings
um to possibly pay off our mortgage of
our primary house or if we use uh should
use savings to pay off the rental and uh
the debt that we have
that's a good question man okay so if I
were you you Hector
um what's the eighteen thousand dollars
in debt
of my wife's car and just uh
okay
I would use some of that seventy five
thousand dollars go ahead and pay it off
and that'll leave you with fifty seven
thousand bucks I'd be debt free by this
afternoon on those on that thing yep and
then
um
forty thousand dollar what was that you
said was free and clear was that is that
an another house that was the property
that's the property okay
um
what were you what were you going to do
with it
um
talking about building on it but it's a
little bit far from where we currently
live so
we kind of just hanging on hanging on to
it right now okay do you know like
percent what would what would it go for
right now
40 000 about 40 50 000 oh sorry it's
worth that okay yeah yeah yep
um you know okay
you know if you're not going to use it
if it's not a piece of ground that
you're like oh that's our dream and we
really want it there's a part of me that
I'm like I would sell it because it's
not going to make an income right it's
not like there's a house on it and so
you could sell it put some of that money
in some of your emergency money and pay
off the rental the 50 000.
um
and then start knocking out your your
primary mortgage
and here's another thing you can do man
um
shoot
Rachel stop me if I'm wrong here but I'm
just following the trying to follow the
baby steps straight up
um
you've got you would have 57 000 bucks
if you paid off that 18 Grand this
afternoon you can take 50 of that and
pay off this next last remaining debt
which is the 50 grand left on that
rental property
and then you only have left your
mortgage
and um You've Got 7 000 bucks in the
bank you sell that property
um that's just dirt just sitting there
you sell it for 40 or 50 Grand and now
you got your money right back or you
roll that money up and you drop your
um you drop your mortgage to I don't
know
uh actually I would keep that I would
keep it in in have my three to six month
emergency fund so yeah I'd sell that
property pay that rental house off do
you like the rental house
um
not too low but I like it as a rental
property sure okay so it makes good
income you feel like if you didn't have
this rental house and you had a paid off
primary house and you had no you guys
had no debt
would you go and be a landlord like
would you choose to to invest in in real
estate
yes my wife and I do like real estate
okay okay let me ask you another math
question what is your monthly mortgage
payment
um it's uh two thousand two thousand
what do you bring home on this uh rental
property what is it what does it net you
um
about two hundred dollars okay
so and again I have a very primitive
mind and I owe no real oh no real estate
okay the way I would look at this in my
home is I'm trading that 200 bucks a
month for my two thousand dollar
mortgage
I would rather have a net gain every
month in my home of eighteen hundred
dollars you see I'm getting there
I would rather pay my mortgage off no
longer send two thousand dollars away
have eighteen hundred have two thousand
bucks minus the 200 I could have been
earning on on real estate and I'd have a
eighteen hundred bucks in my wallet
more every month
and I know that doesn't take into
perceiving that is the rental for that
rental property it's about fifteen
hundred that would be what would be
coming in if we had it paid off if that
matters oh against your mortgage okay
yeah so that's just trading 500 and then
there's the appreciation so
um it's almost six and a half dozen
another I mean honestly Hector if if you
owed for considering what you guys make
and if you owed 200 000 on a rental I
would sell it you guys owe 50. and you
can clean it up with the cell of the
land and the savings and there's a part
of me have a paid for rental use some of
that rental money to go towards your
primary mortgage
um
and and then attack the primary mortgage
and that be your next does that make
sense
yes yep that's that's what I would do
and yeah because and I remember on a on
a different call
Dave who shocked me same kind of
situation and he was like well as the
numbers are working you could have it
paid off and then you throw and I was
like I thought you just say sell
everything you know so I mean you're
pretty close that's what I'm saying yeah
because the ratios are so small and what
you guys have with cash and what you
could get with the sell of the land
um man you could you could get there get
there so quickly but it's a great
question Hector great question yeah and
for those listening this isn't license
just to like oh cool we can go let's go
get a rental yeah yeah no and there's
ratios of income and where they're at
with cash flow
um makes a huge huge difference
um so John I know when issue you don't
have in life
is switching wallets and purses whatever
because I've got such a I got a giant
Costanza wallet that I need a Slimmer
version of oh really well
uh as as a lady you know I have multiple
bags and purses and I was a lady I have
to you know it's like am I am I taking
the big bag am I taking the backpack
because I have all the kids stuff am I
coming to work and I need this part like
I'm switching stuff all the time and so
when we talk about being smart with
money and budgeting having cash
available and having an envelope or an
envelope system is is key to sticking to
your budget so I have the Rachel Cruise
wallet that has multiple envelopes
within the wallets and then we just
launched very recently the Rachel Cruz
slim one just for me there it is the
slim wallet this is just for you let's
call you George John and and it's great
because it's a card holder and
everyone's like that's a lot of cards
for people that just talk about debit
cards listen there are other our
insurance library card license come on
everything but lots of car hold card
holders and then in the back there is
one
um kind of zip feature that holds one
envelope for cash so if you have that
one category you're going to think I
need yeah that I need to uh have cash
for it's there so it's available in
three colors black camel and champagne
this is the one I personally use I love
it because again
uh because I'm switching back and forth
back and forth all the time so it is
made with General uh genuine leather you
smell it that's cool it's so great it's
so great it's cool but we partnered with
our friends at join who's they're out of
India and they're amazing they're a fair
trade company and employ uh people in
really hard hard places and give them
work and trade and skill and they're
amazing so anyways if you want to check
it out
the new ritual Cruise slim wall is
available for 39 go to
ramseysolutions.com today to get yours
thank you Rachel it's a great Christmas
gift and I didn't do this at the top of
this last segment here today's scripture
of the day is Ephesians 4 24 through
22-24 to put off your old self which
belongs to your former manner of life
and is corrupt through deceitful desires
and to be renewed in the spirit of your
minds and to put on the new self created
after the likeness of God and true
righteousness and holiness
Ralph Lauren says the world is open to
us in each day is an occasion to
reinvent ourselves oh did you say Lauren
how am I supposed to say it
is that right me and king Coleman had
the longest talk about this
oh my gosh Lauren do you remember that
Ralph Lauren or Lauren Lauren Lauren he
actually says in the Oprah interview
Lauren hmm he doesn't say Lauren people
claim he does I don't know it's a good
debate I'm gonna disagree with you it's
one of the least productive debates ever
had in in the history of debates so
thanks for bringing that to our lives
you're welcome everyone in this room is
now Dumber for what you've just said hey
I want to thank everybody in the booth
thank you all the listeners and we will
see you soon be kind to one another pay
off your debts
[Music]
foreign
co-host of the Ramsey show did you know
over 18 million people listen to the
Ramsey show every week a lot of those
people listen on one of our 600 plus
radio stations across the country to
find a station near you go to
ramseysolutions.com show
foreign
[Music]